[موسيقى]
حياكم الله في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه صالونها اليوم يناقشوا موضوع
السودان ولكن بطريقه ليست طريق خبريه او
سياسيه اذ ان اخبار السودان تملا الفضاء
وتملا الارض وتملا كل مكان نتمنى ان تكون
اخبار مفرحه لاهلنا في السودان وللناس فكل
الناس الذين يحبون السودان
والسعوديون والعرب هم في مقدمه من يحب هذا
البلد الذي يشكل
ركيزه اساسيه من ركائز العالم العربي
والعالم الاسلامي في وجهه الافريقي عن هذه
النقطه تحديدا وجه السودان اريد ان نتحدث
او نتحدث اليوم لا نريد ان نتكلم في
العاجل من الاخبار القوات الدعم السريع
فعلت مش عارف ايش جيش مش عارف مين مين مع
هذا ومين مع هذا مين اللي على صح ومين
اللي على غلط ومين يدعم هذا ومين يدعم هذا
مش هذا موضوعنا اليوم عشان نكون واضحين من
البدايه موضوعنا هو ابعد من ذلك في ذلك
وهو ما هي هويه السودان الثقافي من هو
السودان وما هو السودان وما هي ركائز
ثقافيه ثقافته وما هي البصمه
نقول الفكريه او التاريخيه او الثقافيه
للسودان بكلمه او باختصار ما هو تعريف
السودان والسودان من زاويه ثقافيه اذ ان
هذا الامر ليس طرفا من الحديث لا هو جزء
رئيس بل محرك رئيس
الصراع نتذكر في هذا الاطار انفصال اقليم
جنوب السودان الذي اصبح دوله اليوم جزء من
محركات هذا الصراع كان موضوع الهويه ولا
اريد ان استاثر بالحديث فلدينا اليوم رجل
يعتبر بالنسبه لي احد
اصحاب المصداقيه للحديث في هذا الامر وهو
الاكاديمي السوداني الدكتور احمد صادق
الباحث في اللغويات وعن هذا الامر عن هويه
السودان واللغه احدى مداخل هذه الهويه
نتحدث دكتور احمد صادق في البدايه حياك
الله ابو عزام اهلا يا استاذ مشاري الله
يخليك دكتور احمد
نضع هذا السؤال في البدايه
ما هي هويه السودان
التحيه لك يا استاذ مشاري والتحيه
للمشاهدات والمشاهدين
السؤال بالغ التعقيد طبعا عرفته لا يمكن
ببساطه عرفت الاجابه عليه ولكن الحد
الادنى من الاستجابه للكلام
السودان واحد من يعني
اللي انت تقول ممكن تقول عليهم بلد
ثقافيا هو بالغ التعقيد يعني عرفتها اللي
هو مالات هذا التعقيد ما نراه من عنف لاحق
يعني عرفت اللي هو الصراع الجوهر هو صراع
هويه
وهويه السودان يعني لا يكفي انك تقول
عليها انها متعدده
ولا يكفي انك تقول عليها فيها اختلاف مثل
ما علماء الاجتماع يفرقون بين تعدد وتنوع
واختلاف اللي هو هذا الخطاب اللاحق لمدارس
علم الاجتماع المعاصر يعني
[موسيقى]
القعر الذاكره الثقافيه السودانيه
هي حقيقه تتميز بهذا الاختلاف يعني اختلاف
عنده ابعاد كثيره جدا جدا
الاستاذ بشاري انا دائما دائما لما تيجي
سيره
الهويه
والاختلاف وارتباطه بالجغرافيا اسمها
السودان
اذكر
قصيده لشاعر من الفاز بجائزه نوبد
القصيده بترجمه يمكن تكون مخله وفيها خفه
يعني لكن يقول انه تجري في عروقي دماء
هولنديه ودماء بريطانيه ودماء زنجيه ودماء
هنديه هنديه بمعنى امريكا اللاتينيه
والسكان الاصليين يعني اما انني لا احد او
انني امه يا سلام ايضا السودان اذا
السودان بهذا المعنى هذا هو هذا هو عرفت
ومن هنا تاتي يعني اسطوره
اول الاساطير المتراكمه حول هويه هذه
الجغرافيا السياسيه يعني خلينا نقول
بابعاده
الجغرافيه السياسيه
عندنا برضو شاعر برضو في نفس السياق يعني
اللي هو المرحوم الدكتور محمد عبد الحي
وكان من المهتمين بامر
الهويه يعني مهموم مشغول في خطابه
الشعر يعني عنده مقطع
الاكثر شيوعا دائما في الكتابات
المختلفه يعني
في في مقطع من القصيده
وكانه يخاطب احدهم يقول له
بدوي انت لا من بلاد الزنجي لا انا منكم
تائه عاده يغني بلسان
يعني بس على ذكر اللسان
العربي في السودان
في جدل
هو جدل ليس خاص بالسودان على فكره ممكن
موجود اكيد تعرفه في سياق
العروبه هي الاساس هي حجر الزاويه في
الثقافه السودانيه ام انها كما يقول البعض
خاصه بعض بلدان المغرب العربي وحتى في بعض
البلدان الاخرى انها هي هي لسان معبر
لكنها ليست هي حجر او المعبر عن الوجدان
دعني اسوق العباره بطريقه اخرى كما ذكر
بعض الباحثين السودانيين الاستاذ محمد
جميل يقول انه كاتب مغربي او جزائم جزائري
اسمه كاتب اسمه فلان كاتب يقول ان اللسان
الفرنسي الذي يتحدث به كثير من الجزائريون
اليوم تعتبر لغتهم الثانيه وعند البعض
لغتهم الاولى لا يعني اننا من الثقافه
الفرانكفونيه هذا غنيمه حرب فهل كما ينادي
بعض النخب المتافقين او
المتافرين يعني من افريقيا والصداع انه
يتعاطى مع العربي المميز في السودان
باعتباره غنيمه حرب وليس معبر عن وجدان
السودان او هو يعني هو ثقافه السودان
الحقيقيه هل ترصد هذا الجدل وماذا تعلق
عليها
نفتكر انك انت الان لمست جوهر المساله
باعتبار انه
اولا انا لا اتفق ربما كثير مما ذهب اليه
هؤلاء الباحثين والاساتذه
اللسان العربي لم يكن طارئا على الاطلاق
في الجغرافيا التي تسمى السودان هذه واحده
الامر الثاني شاع لقرون يا استاذ مشاري
انه اللغه العربيه شاعت بعد دخول الاسلام
وانت تعرف انه في منفذين لدخول الاسلام
والمسلمين في السودان اليوم هذه الجغرافيا
عن طريق البحر الاحمر وعن طريق
ولاحقا عدد من المؤرخين واولهم المقريزي
المصري المعروف
هذا هو زعمهم يعني انه
الشاهد انه عدد من الباحثين
ومن فتره مبكره جدا اثبتوا بدليل ماده
قاطع ان اللغه العربيه كانت شائعه قبل
دخول الاسلام في متوسط
300 الى 400 سنه قبل الاسلام قبل الاسلام
عرفت
وظلت هذه
يعني هذا التواصل فيما بين اللغه العربيه
او الاعراب ممن انتقلوا وهذه معروفه على
فكره تحديدا جهينه وربيعه هذه معروفه
لمعظمهم واولهم ابن خلدون
يعني اللغه العربيه
شاعت في بدايتها كانت خليط من اللهجات
واللغات المحليه
وهذه كلها لغات افريقيه يعني انت ممكن
تقول عليها
لغات افريقيه بكل سماتها الدلاليه
والصوتيه
والتركيبيه الى اخره
استمر هذا الامر الى ان دخل الاسلام وخلاص
يعني يعني شاعه
سرديه يعني هذا الدين عرفت
وتوغل وهذا كان عامل تاريخي في انه اللغه
العربيه يعني تتوغل اكثر عرفت وتصير
اللسان وتعلم ما قاله ابن خلدون
معروف في المقدمه يعني انه غلبه اللغه
بغلبه اهلها
وشاء هذا اللسان ولكن ظلت علامات عديده
موجوده يعني الان مالات هذا التواصل فيما
بين الناطقين باللغه العربيه
واللغات الافريقيه
وبالتاكيد المتحدثين بها هم من الزنج هم
من يعني الافارقه الذين لم يختلطوا باي
دماء عربيه مطلقا وظلت هذه المساله لفتره
طويله جدا بالمناسبه على جنوب السودان
اليوم
هل اللسان العربي موجود اليوم في دوله
جنوب السودان اي نعم ليس اللسان العربي
فقط ولكن هنالك عدد من اللغات الخليط
والهجين بالتحديد الهجين ليه لانه
اللغه يفرقون بين انه ايش خليط وايش
هجين هجين بمعنى انه ثلثي الكلام او اللفظ
هو من اللغه السائده او اللغه
الاكثر شيوعا مثل ما هنا انت تعرف في
الخليج العربي يعني هنالك لغه هجين شائعه
او
اللي هي ثلثيها من اللغه العربيه
اللفظ يعني والثلث الثالث ممكن يكون
[موسيقى]
يعني ممكن يكون اوردو ممكن
الى اخره
ففتره طويله جدا
هنا يقودنا الامر
لتجارب الاستعمار يا استاذ مشاري بس انت
جارب الاستعمار لان الوقت استعمارنا الان
اوكي فيجب ان نذهب حتى لا يحتلنا الوقت
فاصل وجيز ونرجع ونكمل عند هذه النقطه
المهمه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في برنامجكم الندوه
نناقش موضوع هويه السودان الحقيقيه ما هي
هويه السودان بعيدا عن الصراعات السياسيه
والعسكريه الجاريه اليوم لا شان لنا بها
نريد ان نعرف ما هو السودان وما هي هويه
السودان الحقيقيه لان الهويه هي اساس
الاسس وجوهر الجواهر وكان حديثنا وما يزال
مع الباحث السوداني الاكاديميه السوداني
في مجال اللغويات الدكتور احمد صادق
واكاديمي منذ امد من الزمن يدرس في هنا في
السعوديه وقبل ان يدرس في الخرطوم ذو صله
شديده بهذا الموضوع كنت تتحدث دكتور احمد
قبل الفاصل عن بعد ما طوفنا في موضوع
اللغه العربيه ومكانتها في السودان ودورها
في تكوين هويته وتحدثت عن اللهجات الخليطه
والهجينه ثم توقفت عن دور الاستعمار فهلا
اكملت الله يخليك بشوف
واحده من العناصر اللي
بشكل مباشر في تعقيد
سرديه الهويه ان شئت تجارب الاستعمار
المتعدده والمتنوعه التي خضعت لها هذه
الجغرافيا بحدودها اللي هي اصلا رسمها
الاستعمار الاستعمار يعود الى ما قبل
الميلاد طبعا عرفت الممالك النوبيه
القديمه خدعت لاستعمار الفراعنه يعني
الاسر المعروفه في التاريخ
بالاضافه الى
الجغرافيا السودان وحتى هذه اللحظه هي
كانت
ندبه حقيقيه ليش لانه هو في الوسط ومفتوح
على عدد هائل من يعني
الجيوبوليتكس التانيه المجاوره يعني عرفت
هذه حدوده منذ الازل لا طبعا لا طبعا يعني
مره باطوار عديده جدا يعني ما يعرف اليوم
بممالك النيل
هي كانت يعني حدودها من جنوب مصر
وحتى حدود جنوب السودان اليوم او ممكن
بعديه
ببضعه فرازخ ليس اكثر يعني
في كل مره طبعا الجغرافيا السياسيه تتغير
وتعرف الغزوات والتاريخ اللي هو معروف
ومكتوب ومقروء والتواصل معه بيحصل من فتره
الشاهد في هذا الامر يعني انه التجارب
الخضع عليها السودان
كانت متنوعه متعدده اسهمت يا استاذ مشاري
بشكل مباشر في انقطاعات مد قومي
وعلى فكره انا لم اقل هذا الكلام قاله
المفكر الاقتصادي الراحل سميره مين قال
انه السودان والجزائر في المحيط العربي
والافريقي بالتحديد يعني اسوا ما خلفه
الاستعمار ان شئت انه عمل الاستعمار بشكل
مباشر وبشكل غير مباشر حتى كمان على قطع
المد القومي والوطني
وهذه مره مهمه يعني لا تتصور انه
مالات هذا الامر نعاني منها حتى هذه
اللحظه
يعني حتى مساله الهويه نفسها ملتبسه جدا
في كثير من جوانبه لسبب بسيط لانه ما زالت
جينات التجربه بتاعت الاستعمار متجليه في
الخطاب يعني وطبعا اوله خطاب السياسي
وكل
الجوانب الابعاد الثانيه والاثر الاكبر
ويفترض انه نحن ننتقل لموضوع مهم اللي هو
علاقه بهذه النقطه انه كان له اثر مباشر
في البنيه النفسيه للانسان في هذه
الجغرافيا
يعني
خليط يعني عدد هائل من القبائل يعني
البنيه القبليه والبنيه عند هذه النقطه
هذا التباين الاثني والقومي وربما
حتى في السمات والملامح هل الصمغ تعرف
السوداء مشهور بالصمغ العربي بس انا اريد
ان تستخدم الصمغ بشكل مجازي هل صمغ
الاسلام
هو الذي عذاب هذه الفوارق او قرب بين هذه
الفوارق او
خفف من حده هذه التناقضات
ولقرون عديده احسنت تعرف يعني انت تعرف
انه الاديان الابراهيميه كلها هذه هذا كان
واحد من الاجنده انه يفشى السلام بين
الناس يعني عرفت بدون اي تميز هذه واحده
الامر الاخر يعني
دائما دائما هو كان وجه لطبيعه الصراع
الموجود في المنطقه يعني عرفت اللي هو
اسرع
الابعاد اثنيه وعراقيه
واثنيه وعرقيه بالضروره جبليه تعني انه
يعني سرديه اللون هذه عرفت
والدماء الزنجيه والدماء العروبيه لا يعرف
بعض المشاهدين العرب انه داخل السودان في
تمييز لوني حتى داخل السودان طبعا يعني
تمييز
[موسيقى]
للنزاع والصراع هذا الامر يعني شفته لمن
فك مطلقا في لحظه من اللحظات التاريخ من
هذا الاشتباك يعني من البنيه الاثريه
والقبليه ان شئت يعني والعرقيه
وكان عندها تجلياتها طبعا بالتاكيد مثلا
انت لو اخدت عنصر واحد اللي هو
تشكيل دوله وطنيه نيشان ستيت دائما هذه
الجغرافيا كانت تعجز عن هذا الامر وهذا
الامر مرتبط بتجارب في ظني بالتجارب
الاستعمار ليش في واحد اللي هو كرومر
اللورد كرومر معروف هو كان مهندس
الاستعمار البريطاني او الكولونياليه
البريطانيه
هذا الرجل لما راى من من حضور البنيه
الاثنيه وشاف الاشتباكات والنزاعات
القبليه من من منذ فجر التاريخ قال وصيه
الوحيده هذا في كتابه معروف اسمه مصر
الحديثه عرفت في بضعه مجلدات وكان نصيب
السودان منها كبير يعني
قال مما شاهدته
ينبغي على اهل هذه البلد ان يفكروا في
حكومه حقيقيه وليست قوميه او وطني لانه
شهد الرجل لسنوات حكومه عمليه يعني
حقيقيه هو قال ريال كفر من رمضان
يعني ناشونال لانه شاف انه ما راح يكون في
على الاطلاق تجانس وهذا الصراع والاشتباك
اللي جذره قبلي وعرقي حتى الان تحدثت انه
اللسان ذكرنا قبل
الديني كونهم مسلمين في غالبيتهم الساحقه
وايضا العامل اللغوي كون اللسان العربي
اللسان الغالبيه منهم التباينات في
اللهجات طيب عليه يكفي هذان العنصران لخلق
شعور مشترك اضافه تجربه الكفاح او يعني
مثلا حركه المهديه في السودان مثلا هذه
الحمله اللواء مقاومه البريطانيين
والاستعمار البريطاني او كذا والتركي على
يكفي هذا الشعور الوطني بين قوسين بخلق
حاله تلتف حولها المجموعه اما هذا لم يحصل
هي كادة يا استاذ مشاري انها تحصل لحظه
الثوره
المهديه هي لحظه جوهريه جدا في التاريخ
الحديث
اللي هو اواخر القرن التاسع عشر ليش لانه
باعتباره انها اول دوله بعد ثوره
حققت جوانب وطنيه حقيقيه وكانت في محاوله
تاريخيه
ايضا اللي انه كل هذه الاصوات وكل هذا
الاختلاف انه تستوعب والتناقضات تستوعبها
خطاب واحد اللي هو دوله ممكن تقول عليها
دوله وطنيه عرفت التجربه كانت مهمه جدا
انت تعرف انه
في هذاك الوقت
قلت لك في البدايه كلام ابن خلدون اللي هو
غلبه اللغه بغلبه اهله شاعل لسان العربي
عرفت وسبق هذه الثوره بضعه ممالك اسلاميه
معروفه يعني ابتداء من القرن العاشر
الميلادي
ظهور مكتمله الاركان ايوه سلطانات دارفور
عرفت اسمها كثيرا
وعلى فكره يعني
التاريخ الاسلامي تحديدا عرفت في دارفور
اللي فيها الان الصراع وصراع حول الهويه
والموارد الاساسي
يعني
لهم اسهاماتهم المباشره في تاريخ تطور
الدوله الاسلاميه عرفت فيك فيك في الشرق
وفي الغرب في الشام في المغرب خاصه وحتى
اليوم على فكره في علامات كثيره تحيلك
بشكل مباشر الى الى مراكز الحضاره
الاسلاميه الى مراكز الخطاب الاسلامي بكل
جوانبه الى اخره بالاضافه لوسط السودان
اللي هي مملكه سنار يعني عرفت مملكه سنار
اللي هي كانت من اوائل الممالك هي دوله
مكتمله الاركان اللي هو حصل فيها
صلح شهير جدا بين العناصر اللي هي افريقيه
عرفت والعناصر العربيه اللي هو ما يعرف
الفونج والعبد الله والعبد الله بل هم
الاب هذه اب النسبه في عربيه اهل السودان
اللس
العربي حتى بعد الاستعمار البريطاني في
الوثائق الرسميه ومنها اول دستور عام 1953
وحتى اخر دستور اللغه العربيه هي اللغه
الرسميه هي الدوله اي نعم من فتره طويله
جدا بالاضافه لانه القرن 19 هو القرن
العشرين شهدوا عدد هائل من الدراسات ومن
المؤلفات انا انا اريد تدلل على ذلك ان
اضفر هذه الخطوط او الخيوط المتناثره في
ضفيره واحده لاسقط نرجع الى واقعنا احنا
طوفنا بعيدا وقليلا في التاريخ القريب او
البعيد حوله هويه السودان اليوم الدكتور
احمد
هل الصراع الحاصل اليوم هو في وجه من
اوجهه صراع على الهويه في السودان
بالتاكيد وبشكل مطلق
يعني انت ممكن ترد هذا الصراع بطبيعته
واشيائك والمعقده جدا مثل ما انا ذهبت في
البدايه
طبيعه اشكاليه الهويه هذه ترد بشكل مباشر
لهذا التاريخ اللي كنا نحكي عنه من بدايه
الحوار يا استاذ مشاري عرفت بل اكثر من
ذلك شوف مقالات هذاك التاريخ المعقده جدا
ما نراه اليوم من اشتباك ومن صراع ومن عنف
منهجي عرفت الان للاسف يعني عرفت ترد بشكل
مباشر وتحيره بشكل مباشر لهذه الذاكره او
الصراع على الهويه او او جروح الذاكره
كمان بالتاكيد هذا هو هذا هو للاسف هذه
الذاكره اله الى هذا الحقيقه ان الحديث لا
يمل معك دكتور احمد رغم الموضوع في جوانب
منه ممتعه فيها ثقافيه وفكريه وفي جوانب
منهم مؤلم لانه كما قلت في بدايه الحديث
الجميع يريد للخير يريد الخير لاهل
السودان قبل اهل السودان انفسهم عاجز عن
شكرك الدكتور احمد وان شاء الله لنا فرص
اخرى في مناسبات اجمل وتطواف ارحب وكما
اشكركم مشاهدينا على هذه الدقائق التي
تشاطرناها لنناقش موضوع هويه السودان ما
هو السودان ومن هو السودان الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]